strange conditions to say the least on
Thursday night in Winnipeg Manitoba has
the Packers and Raiders realized there's
a problem when you relocate the
goalposts when you literally move the
goalposts for FL game on a Canadian
field it created an issue with the turf
in the end zone
they made the field 80 yards long look
at that if you're watching on a BCS and
this is comical the Gulf the the pylon
goes to the 10 the 20 becomes the 30
that then becomes the 20 it's not
reflective of what the NFL is trying to
project Chris and and I think there's
got to be some people at the league
office this morning who were very upset
with what happened but it's given us an
idea oh yeah just feel you didn't like
this one I don't care I got the trump
card here strangest field conditions in
NFL history and we determined the first
pick no longer with the rigged coin toss
I've got a trivia question and I
actually lobbied Chris to make this one
easier okay I thought it was J was too
difficult as originally drafted here we
go for the first pick in the draft Chris
Sims in what state was the first NFL
game played oh my gosh that is a really
good question and I I'm really gonna be
mad if I don't get this but what state
was the first I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
with Illinois that's a shame thanks for
playing Ohio that's where the first game
sites did dog Dayton triangles took on
the Columbus panhandles October 3rd 20
or 1920 so that 100th anniversary is
coming up October 3rd obviously if 2020
first game ever played Dayton triangles
and the Columbus Panhandle alright I get
the first pick and whoo-hoo all right
stranges field conditions yeah this can
go that's a broad category it
deliberately broad and I have to go with
the ultimate snow globe game the Tuck
rule game the game that birthed the
Patriots dynasty that one comes up on
this program from time to time in these
drafts but there was nothing stranger or
more magical than that night in January
of 2000 and
- when the Raiders and the Patriots got
together and it was a thing of beauty
the highlights are still fun to watch
unless you're a Raiders fan because to
this day they still believe that was a
fumble the field goals made by Adam
Vinatieri in the snow the last game ever
played at the Patriots old Stadium and
you know I don't know is that game still
remembered as as magically as if if the
Patriots hadn't won the Superbowl I
don't know but it was a special special
night and those were some strange fuel
conditions field conditions that we love
to see when they happen but when you
take the magnitude of the game with the
outcome yeah with the conditions that's
one of the most memorable games in my
view other than a Super Bowl in NFL
history
Mike I'm with you man that was an
amazing game to watch I mean I can still
remember I believe it was a Saturday
Night Football game right - the Raiders
Jon Gruden oh this new offense that's
been unleashed on the NFL and damn this
upstart Tom Brady and you know Bill
Belichick and everything my dad was
actually announcing the football game it
was phenomenal watching on TV I can
remember being at the University of
Texas watching with my friends I did not
write that one down so kudos to you for
that one that was a good one that I
certainly overlooked and yeah it's the
Tuck rule game but it was still a lot of
fun to watch it was magical I'm with you
there
all right I'm gonna go to the ice ball
okay I gotta go to the Ice Bowl for the
fact of just the magnitude just like
you're saying this is the chance to play
in first Super Bowl right you got the
Cowboys and the Packers and Vince
Lombardi and they're up there in Green
Bay Wisconsin they got the heaters
underneath the field well they put the
tarp over the field I guess and with the
cold and the heat it kind of made the
field moist to them when they took the
tarp off the field the field became ice
hence the ice ball but certainly one of
the more magical games in the history of
the NFL Bart Starr and the one-yard
quarterback sneak because you know the
footing wasn't great and the guard
Kramer leading them into the end zones
one of the greatest photos in the
history of the NFL I thought that one
was one of the first ones that popped in
my brain yeah that's on my list as well
and the field conditions
but when you consider the field itself
and everything around it there's been
nothing like it there's been some games
close to being is called but nothing
like the ice ball and that does continue
to resonate alright I'm gonna go back to
the stadium where the site of my
first-round pick occurred the the old
Schaeffer Stadium where the Patriots
played until they opened Gillette
Stadium 1982 the conditions were the
same there was snow but there was a
benefit the snow ball Patriots head it
was the snowplow game yeah I gets on the
snowplow he runs out it creates a path
for the field goal Don Shula blows a
gasket of a December of 1982 the
Patriots win the game that's a Reno
thanks to that fuel roll and that's one
of the old-time great highlights to the
guy on the snowplow runs out there
creates a path course they changed the
rules after that you're not allowed to
bring snow plows onto the field anymore
but there really wasn't anything they
could do about it at the time New
England kick the field goal won the game
three to nothing December of 1982 the
strike shortened season by the way 82
that is awesome I mean I don't know what
I would have done if I was Don Shula I I
mean I've seen that highlight of him
blowing a gasket over there
I really think if I was the head coach
of the Dolphins at a time I would have
ran out on the field on that moment and
kicked snow back onto that spot they
were trying to bulldoze the snow off or
plow the snow off of so good one by you
I had that written down as well okay I
think you missed a better one though the
fog Bowl 1988 playoffs bears Eagles
starts off as this beautiful day
wow it's clear crisp day in Chicago this
is gonna be great to watch football I
can still remember being a young kid
sitting at home watching it and damn all
of a sudden you got into what was it
that a late second quarter early second
quarter the fog rolls in and you
couldn't watch the damn game anymore you
couldn't see anything really every now
and then you got a glimpse of a guy here
a glimpse of a guy there but you were
really just going off what the announcer
said that will always you know ring true
to me as far as just one of the most
interesting 'rememorable games I can
ever remember yeah I remember trying to
watch that game on TV and I finally gave
up it's like what's the probably know
this is kind of a neat effect but
at the same time I can't see anything it
was impossible to know what was going on
but there's never been another one like
it and that I remember you can find that
game on YouTube it was a clear blue sky
bright beautiful day when they did the
introductions it was picturesque yeah
and yeah by halftime
it became the pea soup and that's a good
one
I didn't have that one on my list just
like you didn't have the Tuck roll on
your list all right here's one that I'm
taking a little bit of a liberty here
and it actually created two unusual
games because when the Metrodome
imploded in December of 2010 with one of
the all-time great videos of you could
see that old soft roof it was starting
to go under the weight of the blizzard
that happened in Minnesota and it was
starting to go and when it finally
started you see the snow starting to
come through and then it just goes that
forced the Vikings to play a home game
against your New York Giants in Detroit
hit Ford Field how about that right
likings hosting the Giants in Detroit
and then for a Monday night football
against the Bears which would end up
being the final game of Brett Favre's
career he suffered a concussion when his
head hit the frozen turf because they
didn't have a system at the college
Stadium in Minnesota unfreeze the turf
because they didn't play home games in
December there that was the second game
that was their first foray into the what
was it that it's the Sun Bank Stadium
not us Bank and TNT or and was no
clothes no clothes but not even close
but but anyway where the University of
Minnesota plays its home games so the
Vikings had to go on the road and along
the way the Vikings had a game delayed
in Philadelphia by two days due to a
blizzard we were there for that game it
was an NBC game the game was cancelled
on Sunday night huge blizzard came in
the games played Tuesday and all of us
went down to Philadelphia via train for
that game it was just a crazy couple of
days in New York snow was everywhere so
that was the that was a that was an
upside down month of December for the
Vikings back in
2010 but it all started when that
Metrodome roof collapsed yeah that that
was that was kind of crazy and really
tough for the Minnesota Vikings PNC Bank
Stadium I do believe is what's nuts oh
no I hear no I'm wrong okay nope
keep trying oh he said someone it's some
initials with a bank after it I give up
I don't even give a damn okay it really
narrows it down he all right go ahead
okay um I gotta go with Super Bowl xlvii
okay I mean I'm gonna go with Super Bowl
xlvii I know this is a little different
but I mean the lights went out in the
freakin Super Bowl okay and you know of
course there's all the conspiracy
theories and the NFL did this
deliberately so the 49ers could you know
rebound and regather themselves because
it was gonna be a blowout but I just
think the magnitude it's the most
watched event in all of TV every year
and yes it did look like the Ravens were
gonna run away with the football game
and BAM the lights went out now I don't
believe in the conspiracy theory but
either way it is a night I'll never
forget because we sat there for what was
it between 20 and 30 minutes right
before they actually got the power back
on and got we got back to playing
football and it was just funny to see
you know guys like Ray Lewis and
everybody sitting there on the sidelines
like okay I guess we just sit here and
hang out but the Super Bowl until they
let us play again Ray Lewis definitely
believes it was a conspiracy theory I
was up in the press box and at the Super
Dome the press box is basically stapled
to the roof of the facility so you're
the last one's getting out and Mike
Silver who at the time I think was with
Yahoo now with nfl.com he just blurted
it out in a loud voice do you think this
is a terrorist attack it's like well
that's a way to get everybody to stay
calm so that was a and and my wife was
in the stadium at night so you know
we're texting like where are you where
do you go like we didn't know we had a
period of time we're like what the
hell's going on but there's nothing we
can do we just got to sit here and wait
until it all gets figured out all right
TCF Bank Stadium you know the folks at
TCF Bank are probably going to now
revisit whether or not they want to
continue to sponsor that stadium because
it didn't work it
it's some initials Bank Stadium I don't
know but it's TCF Bank Stadium that's
where the Vikings spent a couple of
seasons and also played that game
against the Bears on the Monday night in
2010
all right not a bad dress yes all right
you were opposed but it worked out well
Tucker rule games a blob game and the
Metrodome collapses forcing the Vikings
those the Giants in Detroit you've got
the Ice Bowl the fog Bowl and Super Bowl
xlvii we're to take a break when return
continue to get you ready for week three
of the 2019 NFL preseason
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports